well you're in one of the big movies
this summer the suicide squad are you so
stoked
oh my god i'm really excited yeah i'm
excited i love the posters
how look they are i think how good they
look i'm so excited i'm into like
anything like this
it's like any super i'm into anything
like this
were you as a kid i was i was since i
was a little kid i loved
comic books yeah and i was actually
really really blessed that he was able
to do a marvel film which is new mutants
a while ago and now suicide squad which
is dc which for a nerd
kid that i was it's it was a dream
different yeah
yeah i really really loved it no and
this one i think the fans are really
gonna love it because james gunn the
director
he's so brilliant he directed um
guardians of the galaxy yeah
which i love i love it and it's so much
fun there's so much laugh
in it even though there's explosions and
all the craziness
the comedy in those films are always my
fa it's because the moments were
that's the best kind of comedy just by
the trailer you're going to see the vibe
of the film it's really powerful
i'm so stoked for you yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever